corty Hey
[Music]
I'm pretty sure Hank would think it's
awesome if I made all hammers disappear
is it gone
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday to five yard Oh
forehead it's nice in our stand even
though we didn't turn as I planned
this more annoyin and
you know what it was wonderful a we were
journaling by a string whoever so I
wanna do something when I am over you it
will be great
[Music]
the thought of you is someone else makes
me wanna do the Shelf of all the shoot
you games and me throw it on the window
see you fly through the air because yell
it out so they all know that I'm gonna
let you go I'm gonna way you go
[Applause]
Hank celebration happy birthday I drew
you this picture of you on Mars in
nerdfighteria I'm gonna dance with it
happy dance
and that
maybe
and bear Hank we gotta take climate
change we're gonna make it this big
hey Hank do you think this is awesome
I don't think knees pill and Keith look
at around morning John it's May 10th
2008 and this is the biggest can of easy
cheese I've ever seen hey my scientist
who shows me a picture on the big red
circle with a green smudge on top my
scientist says that's an apple I say
okay an Apple user
very well done he says you are a woman
and I am a scientist I am a human and
well here's something else because this
is existence a welcome to existence and
many fruits mash which in turns me off
my scientists and wears thick rimmed
glasses and works in a lab he doesn't
speak much nice scientists stairs into
microscopes scratches his head and he
doesn't say much
I say hey mr. scientist let's go outside
you talk about outside don't you never
go out here as I am a scientist
I got work to do and work is down
[Music]
my scientist and sits on the corner of
the bed he is crying so I asked him
what's wrong my scientists and says you
are dying and say what is dying uses
never mind so he sits together on the
corner of the bed and nothing else I
said I just sit there together and I
touch his hand and he touches mine then
he first lofts which intends me up my
scientist stands with his back to me
waiting for the answers to appear before
his eyes my scientists didn't see it
come and do even have a chance to beg or
cry so I carry him back to the corner of
the bed and put a pillow beneath his
bloody head and then I stand up brush
off walk to the door turn out the lights
and go outside happy birthday happy
birthday happy birthday hey Hank I drew
this picture for you I hope you like it
I got my voters information in the other
day and I guess the government thought I
was awesome enough to actually change my
middle name too
awesome hey joy happiness I think so
Hank I made this video so many times
that your corn dog
hey hey hey chances are you're not as
fancy as the bear a very magic as mr.
fancy-pants beware when everybody's
smart you in the fancy pen for me he's
gonna pass the test gonna be the best
the best in terms of pants you looking
every catalog shop in every store even
though you have a Underpants you want
some more
the greatest that you've ever seen even
though you know it cost a lot of dough
you have to have the world's best pants
thankee
[Music]
he said
to make the big announcement and the
trophy goes to you your dog you had some
fancy pants and now you know it's true
look at mr. fancy pants and all katoki
hi everybody cheers I was biking back
the tears he doesn't even have the best
pants
we do
nerdfighter and burbank ha
pander fighters stank for my act sector
project this semester we created a
museum that talks about transportation
and its effect on the environment have
you gotten a hank kids the growler in
haunted sweet and uglier
it's not much but it's something
something awesome
[Music]
happy birthday Hank Hank this is nervous
or wishing you a very happy birthday
dftba
so goodbye 27 year old you in honor of
your birthday Hank I bought a scooter
which I've been riding to work nearly
every day except when it rains
happy birthday Hank green it is in your
honor that I recycled today I'm shopping
with my reusable Earth Day bag is this
I can I shove a cycle her birthday Hank
don't forget to be awesome
nerdfighters oh hey for your birthday
would you rather have the third twin in
your pants or the doctor secret child in
your pants
happy birthday
13 beeps pretend that's a cake every day
here's a cookie happy birthday hey happy
belated birthday Hank
happy birthday Hank nerdfighters
[Music]
yes it is up without Southport it is
Laura no indeed that is a get cocky
Moses am a producer I myself don't Yap
is a garbage monster spit by destroy it
a blue actor lost the most delicate area
police rubric to pass downtown but oh my
god why Lucy
I feel like this bad yesterday
I'm all for dead
my mother is
s tud that's what you are to me